today I want to talk about the 32 most
difficult personalities anybody could
deal with and I'm not talking about self
pity and title blame or victimhood that
I've talked about in the past before I'm
talking difficult personalities that
you've dealt with them by the way before
I get into it so you could poke fingers
at other people remember this
everybody is difficult to somebody
[Music]
before I get into it valuators I want to
talk about what happened last week when
I was at the mall I saw this husband and
wife with their kid in their stroller
they're walking with the official value
taemin I'm an entrepreneur sure they saw
me I saw them they came up to me they
said oh my gosh we're diehard value
Tanner's we've never met you before and
I see this shirt in airports I see
people sending me messages on Twitter on
Instagram on snap saying Pat I love it
when I see other value tenders that are
wearing this year because the community
knows each other so you if you're
watching this if you don't yet have this
gear click on the link below go pick a
shirt out for yourself order one wear it
tag me on instagram tag me on twitter
we're gonna share some of them on our
content in the future now I haven't said
I'll let me get into the difficult
personalities here's the part you got to
realize you heard what I said when I
said everybody is difficult to somebody
right but there is good difficult there
is bad difficult you'll see what I mean
by them some of them I'm going to
explain to you and some of these are
pertaining me as both sides we're
watching this the part I don't want you
to do I don't want you to just watch
this and say oh that's how she is oh
that's how my mom is oh that's how my
dad is oh that's how this person is
because everybody all the people on the
outside day in changes you got to look
for the ones that's you and say what do
I need to do to fix this part about me
that is not a good difficult personality
that hopefully will help you do better
with the people that you're dealing with
so let me get right into it Mario and I
sat down and by the way every one of
these personalities there's a name right
next to it some of them are my names
some of them are other people's names
some of them is Mario's they believe it
or not but it's everybody that we know
that we kind of put it up then all of us
on categories came out number one
attitude I mean I've dealt with a lot of
difficult people but the simplest one is
somebody who's got a pessimistic
negative attitude that's always
complaining and it's a downer all the
time very difficult personality to be
around number two passive you'll be in a
meeting and you're expecting people to
participate and give their ideas they
don't say anything there
somebody's pushing them and they don't
voice their opinions their passive
somebody is challenging them they don't
say anything they're passive that
becomes difficult because the value
everybody has some kind of a value to
bring in a meeting we're not able to get
the value out of that person because
they're being passive so if somebody
that's passive you thinking to yourself
I'm kind of a passive personality bother
most of you watching are probably gonna
have this feeling as one of them
majority of a lot of people you got to
kind of get yourself out there because
if you're sitting in a meeting you don't
voice your opinion nobody sees you as a
potential leader to come up someone's
got to know what is on your mind so you
got to come prepared and say here's what
I think we need to do to improve this
department improve this business improve
this company improve this division
whatever it is it is so being passive
sometimes it's one fastest way to not
get promoted or growing your business
number three too emotional we've had
people in the past before when I say too
emotional we had somebody that we fired
and we were talking about a really nice
guy just a sweetheart of a guy but too
often things would happen he would just
start crying it was way too much where
it was every single time something
happened it was waiting I'm dealt with
these types of personalities probably 20
30 40 times in my career where it was
way too emotional and when that happens
here's what takes place when somebody
immediately starts crying the opposition
is afraid of giving you real counsel and
feedback because they're thinking to
themselves if I say it there's going to
be more crime and people don't like to
be around other people that constantly
cry in the first place because it's not
a habit of a leader so sometimes being
too emotional it's very difficult to
work with somebody like that so the
solution typically for a company becomes
we just have to replace him and get him
to another place if that's you keep in
mind in a business environment in an
environment that's growing being too
emotional doesn't serve you at all next
number four out do you you ever seen a
movie Boogie Nights right Boogie Nights
is what it's called and there was a
scene so funny we had a guy named
paddock in the army he says Pat this
movie came out we gotta watch this movie
so all the guys we have no clue at the
movie is thirty of us we sit and we we
buy this movie from px which is Army's
Walmart and we put it in we watch we're
like what are we watching over here is
the story of a porn star so but it's
it's it's Mark Wahlberg it's insane you
know it's great and all the stuff that
he's doing and there's a scene where the
guys say so what do you bench he says I
bench 180
five he says what do you bench I bench
190 okay that's cool
hey so how high do you jump you know
high jungle you know I jump this much
what do you curl I curled this I could
what do you you know a squat I squat 225
squat 230 you ever met people like that
they're annoying aren't they it's always
like they gotta outdo you but I'll do
it's negative let me take the positive
side of me they're competitive you know
what I'm saying they always like you
tell a story I remember one time I was
going in and here's what happened the
car was going so fast oh my gosh let me
tell what happened with me
so it's semi annoying but if it's
competitive when all the air there is
and they perform I'm okay with it I can
deal with that as long as that
competitiveness bleeds into performance
as well but there's a part of it that
can be difficult at times number five
aggressive aggressive is somebody that
wants to come in take charge here's what
we're doing this is what we're doing
next here's what we're going people
somebody I want to take charge that
could be positive but that can also
allow other people to not really voice
their opinions at times so it can be
negative and positive so number number
six to salesy somebody who is always
selling I'm talking everything to them
it sells by the way I think everything
in life is sales but there's everything
in life as sales
then there's saying it to everybody 24/7
I've had guys in my life that ever oh
he's got my money I've got to go get
this guy that guy's got this I got
everything is about that all the time
it's a little too much it's a little too
much now let me give you the other
samurai I said positive negative that
can help in the world of sales but not
necessarily if you're trying to run a
big business and allow him to have other
talent to come to you if it's way too
salesy sometimes people don't trust that
personality too often so could help in a
sales business when you're solo by
yourself but to build a massive Empire
maybe it's gonna hurt you a little bit
number seven fake people who are fake
with boy dumb business for a lot of fake
people that's just very easy they look
at you in your face and they tell you
everything they want you want to hear
from them and on all of us and they're a
whole different person an hour later two
hours later the next day and they're
like wait a minute what happened didn't
we just have a meeting and they time it
and a time when they want to tell you
this it's like you know kids one day no
one to ask you for you know money and
that can I get this and they time it
like when you're happily me go ask them
there's a little bit of fakeness there
but it's very difficult to do business
with fake P because you have no idea
who's gonna show up the next day eight
everything is a joke now let me say
about everything
this is fine if I'm going to bar with
you and we're hanging out and you make
me laugh for five hours straight but
there's a different story with
everything is a joke meaning let me
explain to what I mean by this I work
with a guy in our office I can't think
of a single time are you reminding me of
this I can't think of a single time that
he wouldn't do a Borat sign it was like
well what was the Lions Mauri it was
what I liked and then what was the other
one every single time so eventually no
one took that seriously nobody takes it
serious if you're constantly joking
around because if you're constantly
joking around it's being over
compensated for something that's lacking
here and humor is great to break the ice
but 24/7 there's some myths in there so
humor spine but not overly because it
kind of takes away from serious sense of
getting a job done as well number nine
is overpower opposite sex I've dealt
with women who enjoy to overpower men
and I've dealt with men who enjoy to
overpower women I've dealt with both
neither is effective just so you know
now it is effective if you just want to
attract women and you are a woman and it
isn't effective if you're a man and you
just want to attract other men that can
be effective but it's not effective if
you're trying to build a business of
husbands wives women men single married
it doesn't matter everything you've got
to be able to learn how to deal with
everybody but I've dealt with some
people that they just want to control
the opposite sex 24/7 ten condescending
I dealt with the guy like this in the
past before and we have some of this at
the home office well sometimes as
leaders you know we can be condescending
ourselves and we don't even know then
you have to catch yourself it happens a
lot now sometimes in certain
environments it's a lot like you I was
in a military before and sports and it's
constant shots and sarcasm and
condescending and comments and remark so
there were people in the military I
remember vividly there were people in
the middle who can handle it who were
ETS early less than an honorable because
they couldn't handle they wanted to get
up because it was way too much of that
but the military is 24/7 I've heard kids
who play on sports teams who cannot
handle when their coach or other players
are like that and
oh that was a little bit too much for me
but in the sports world environment
sometimes it gets very competitive and
the smack-talking takes place I mean if
you look at basketball let me tell you
draymond Green probably does this all
the time and he gets under other
people's skin you know who else I can
name you 20 30 40 people and the world
of sports to do this is that a positive
is that a negative it can be a positive
and it can be a negative very simple
that could work for you in a very
competitive environment it can hurt you
because you're gonna lose some of the
people that their development process of
becoming competitive or coming up may be
a slower pace so you will lose them
where in another environment the
condescending was lured though people
will stick around so it's all about who
you want to keep in the environment
they're you building right now number 11
know-it-all uncoachable they know
everything they simply know everything
you cannot teach them anything they were
always brag about their degree or how
smart they are
they will always remind you that they're
smarter than your bother what I'm also
good in math I'm also smart
I'm also this you're not the only person
it's not at all I know what I'm doing
you can't give any direction to them so
now is that a good or bad that can't be
good and that can be a bad what do I
mean by that I don't mind a person
that's uncoachable to another person
that's a small thinker what do I mean by
this let me explain to you say I'm
raised by parents who are small thinkers
and they keep telling me to go take the
safe route and I'm saying not I want to
listen to it I don't want to do that
yeah but you gotta go and get a degree
but I'm not built to go to school I'm
telling you I don't want to do anything
to do with school but you gotta go to
college I don't want to go to college
that uncoachable 'ti can be fine if the
kid knows exactly what he or she wants
and they're not lazy now for some of you
that say I relate to this path that's
exactly who I am but you play video
games 24/7 and you're lazy and you put
on a lot of weight at 18 years old I'm
not talking about you cuz you're lazy
period I'm talking about the kid that at
14 years old has already started selling
at 12 years said he was selling stuff at
lemonade stands he washed his car she
goes around cleaning stuff the kid works
hard all the time makes money on
Saturdays and Sundays if this kid wants
to tell his parents I want to be an
entrepreneur that may be a good sign of
on coachability
right so there is good there is about
it's not all bad in that area number 12
uncommitted afraid to commit there's
always an out I've dealt with people
like this and for many many years
see how I handle these uncommitted
people it was always about trying to
convert them right but I'm telling you
it's good but you gotta get it can you
imagine if you do it about that
constantly eventually I realize this is
how they're on their personal lives this
is how they run their business lives
this is how they're with their friends
with their girlfriends with their wives
with their husbands with everybody they
don't commit so which means what there's
always an out so no matter how much you
pour into them and the more you pour
into them the more they think you need
them the more they try to abuse you does
that make sense
so you have to be very neutral with
these personalities because they're
frightened by committing and there's
always an out for them so you have to be
very nimble when you dance with these
guys don't get too close don't get too
emotional don't get too friendly with
them because they're probably gonna end
up taking advantage you and mess with
your mind give a distance to them let
them do what they want they don't want
to come in no problem it's all good go
out there and get it so odds are they're
probably not going to commit to anything
that they don't want to commit to leave
them alone give them direction create a
condition for them to grow if they want
to do it great if they don't they will
move on and they'll do their own part
number thirteen enjoy rejecting
everything I've sat in boardrooms no
matter what I do come up no no no no no
no no by the way nothing wrong with this
if it's no no no because you're trying
to stay with your money and you're not
trying to say yes to everything there's
a part of it that's good to say no but
to always say no and reject every single
idea 24/7 what that does is yes risk may
be minimized but there's a possibility
of that upside opportunity I was coming
your way there you're not gonna get
because you always say no right and
sometimes somebody in a boardroom an
ideation type of an environment that's
always rejecting every idea they bring
more out down more out comes down so a
lot of times you've got to take those
guys out of the ideation room and when
you're coming up with ideas come up with
people that are coming up with positive
ideas then when you need a devil's
advocate bring that person inside and
say tell us all the reasons why this is
not gonna work believe me they're going
to find all the reasons why that's not
gonna work sometimes gonna have a lot of
people that are gonna give you reasons
that it's gonna work and you need to be
able to hear somebody that's gonna tell
you 220 reasons that it's not gonna work
app somebody at work we're here at the
home office let me tell what I do any
positive ideas that comes up
it's automatic finding in the negative
in it every single time so I've told
Mario until we have all the information
we don't need to let that loose to that
person until we have figured out exactly
what it is then we do and then let them
come in and break the whole thing down
and tell us what's going on with that
place and then we move on okay number
fourteen unclear people who are unclear
they don't know what they want you can't
lead a person that's unclear you can't
do business with somebody that's unclear
you can't be in a relationship with
somebody that's unclear there's not a
lot of things you can do with somebody
that's unclear number fifteen arrogant
arrogant arrogant this is somebody that
thinks they're above everybody you know
how I said earlier things are smarter
than everybody this is slightly
different with arrogance because it's
like a it's an aura about them there's
this level of arrogance about them that
makes it difficult for other people to
want to collaborate number sixteen
character issues let me tell you what I
mean by character issues stealing
cheating lying criminal activity forgery
anything that they do that hurts the
entire company you cannot tolerate any
of this stuff you got to figure that out
early because a lot of times I've seen
many big empires many many big empires
fall because somebody tolerated another
person's bad character and bad habit it
didn't show up in a year it didn't show
up in five years but it did show up in
ten years and when it did the Empire was
bigger so the fall was a bigger fall
than a smaller fall but I've seen this
many many times you cannot compromise
character issues within a company number
17 triangulate let me tell you what's
triangulate so for instance imagine
you're doing business with somebody and
they want me to make something happen
right they'll go to Mario they'll go to
Tom they'll go to let you say somebody
else at the Home Office
they will pin the three together and
they'll call me and they'll say Pat said
this or hey Mario said this and they'll
pin the three people together to get a
decision done and then we now have
conflicts against each other because
this person is triangulating okay
we've had people like this in the past
before and the way you have to address
it the way I address it all the time the
guys at the home office know what I do I
call the individual I said listen we are
not fans of triangulating as you're
going through making decisions on things
like this here's what needs to take
place if it's a decision that involves
three different departments I want
everybody to be involved
the communication before we decide what
we're doing and I'm the last person and
my last person that comes to me as they
come give me an update then we get on a
call then we make a decision but do not
triangulate because you're pinning
people against each other and there are
some people that do a lot of training in
triangulating it's not an effective
method to bring people together in a
work environment number 19 a liar and
that's pretty easy I did a video once
Mario what was that one video we did
that's right who should you trust in
business was an episode that we did and
I talked about different types of line
and that gets a little bit more into
detail if you if you do want to watch
that but you know it's difficult to deal
with people that always lie or
constantly lied there's different style
of them some of them are petty and
they're not that big of a deal but some
of them are very big you gotta know
which level of line it is so if you want
to find out what it is go watch that
episode number 20 people who hate losing
let me explain to what I mean by people
who hate losing this updated updated
gross who hated losing and I've done
business with people who hate losing and
this isn't difficult in a negative way
if they're self-aware let me explain
sometimes a person who hates losing so
bad right before in their mind they know
they're about to lose they don't even
know they're doing it because they're
not conscious of this they start hurting
other relationships to make the
reasoning for losing not that big of a
deal I don't know if that made any sense
it's kind of like you know you already
know you're about like you know a
football or basketball you already know
you're about to lose a game then you do
a flagrant foul let known s not
necessary while you're doing a flagrant
foul you know that's because of
frustration you know you're about to
lose you're so upset that anybody who
speaks to you during that moment you're
an absolute jerk to everybody now is
there a positive in that yes I don't
mind people who don't like to lose I
love people who hate to lose but there's
sore losers and there's people who need
to realize that when you lose you got to
go shake hands at the end of every
baseball game t-ball game they teach
them you gotta go high-five the opponent
they do this in World Series they do
this in sports and it sucks
remember when Michael Jordan beat Isiah
Thomas and the Detroit Pistons and
Detroit Pistons walked up and you see
Isaiah Thomas walking like this right
back past the bench and they did in high
high five that's somebody who hates Lou
Lutz but it's a sore loser you lost I
remember one time I'll never forget one
time I lost and somebody brought me on
stage and they made me
give the other person the trophy this
was in front of 600 people I got up I
gave it to him
they were condescending they took a lot
of shots at me I don't mind it because I
love that kind of stuff and I gave a
message from stage to him and I said you
deserve it you outwork me but this will
be the last time ever for the rest of
your life you will ever beat me in this
game ever it's game over from here on
but having said that congratulations to
you enjoy this victory I want to sat
down never ever ever did they ever get
close because I hate to lose but I
didn't mind the stage because I had to
address the issue that I didn't work
hard it's okay so if you're watching it
that's a little bit of you you gotta
adjust because you're hurting some
relationships simply because you hate to
lose and you know you're about to lose
and you rub up to people the wrong way
and you become difficult next 21 a true
believer
let me explain to our true believer
recently I sat with Gloria Allred Gloria
Allred is the enemy's gonna come out
here some Gloria Allred is responsible
for the if you ever see her you know
what sexual harassment law so she was
there for Bill Cosby she was there with
Weinstein she was there with a lot of
different presidents a lot of different
people that had any kind of you know
assault that they did to someone else
it's typically sexual harassment over a
quarter of a billion dollars this
woman's won in lawsuits specifically
around sexual harassment right her and I
are sitting down in our office and I'm
speaking to her I kept telling you're a
true believer you're a true believer
you're true believer you're true
believer by the way here's what happens
with a true believer you better believe
there's a group that hates true
believers because they're so difficult
you know why they're so difficult
because they can't help themself but
keep talking about what they believe in
they cannot help themselves it's 24/7
and the only people that appreciate a
true believer is another true believer
at the same level as them in a complete
different space makes sense true
believers understand other true
believers that doesn't mean a true
believer likes the other true believer
that doesn't be glory and I agree on
everything in life you will see the
interview it's pretty controversial we
get out of pretty quickly but I respect
the hell out of somebody that's a true
believe that consistently this woman for
50 years has been going around the same
message over and over and over and over
over again that's difficult so in a
world of a business picture this say
somebody in the business is a true
believe and everybody's kind of like a
believer and somebody's just there for
money or their doubters all this other
stuff this true believers non-stop cell
under vision what we're going what we're
going where we're going what we're going
some believers will become true
believers some non-believers will become
believer but some doubters will stay
Downers because like listen I don't even
want to hear that stuff that's okay this
is still a difficult person but it's a
positive difficult person if what they
believe in is a worthy positive cause
this is a good thing you want more true
believers there was a book called the
true believer it's about 180 pages
technical book great book to read it
talks about what it is to be a true
believer number 22 selfish let me
explain to what I mean by selfish I have
a name right next to selfish okay I have
a name right next to selfish and here's
what selfish is there's good selfish
there's bad selfish let me explain to
what both of them are what's a good
selfish good selfish is somebody that
wants to win so bad that they pull
everybody else above with them to also
win but they're wanting to win so
flippin bad that would you like it or
not you're gonna win with them because
they're gonna drive expectation high
with everybody
then there are selfish people that wanna
win so bad but they don't want to do the
work they want everybody else to do the
work and they want to take the credit
and I've dealt with people like this
before and I'm just telling you once
they're exploited people leave okay
because nothing is more annoying than
dealing with somebody that's so selfish
in the area of winning that's all about
them and not all the other people it's
okay when somebody wants to win so bad
they like oh my gosh this guy's so
difficult to frickin do business with
well behind closed doors there used to
be a coach in baseball skipper's and I
was Tony Larusso he's still around it
was an attorney before very very
educated guy I think he went to some Ivy
League school and it became a skipper I
think for Oakland A's and players would
say about Tony LaRussa once you realize
how bad this person wants to win you
will have such an easy time playing with
this person once you realize how bad
this person wants to win you will enjoy
and appreciate this person more once you
realize that
that man is selfish but it's positive
selfish you know why because it's kind
of cool when you're also one they're
gonna be able to talk about the fact
that you have a championship ring why
because you worked with somebody that
was so flippin driven and selfish to
want to win that brought all these other
people with them to the top that they
also want that is a positive you need to
know the difference and it's very easy
to tell the two selfish people apart
just watch habits that's all you got to
do watch habits but I got a name right
here on who it it's a few of them but I
got one main name right here I got a
cover this quickly so you can see what
we're talking about Maury can they see
it number 23 is the following let me
tell with number 23 is no need to
improve that no desire to improve really
I mean there's we had a person here that
we were reading the book we were reading
a book I don't know what book it was
that we're reading was a book of the
month right and it was a 500 page book
that we were reading and one of our
employees said I don't know why we have
to read a book like this I said listen I
want to simplify it for you at our
company if you don't read this book per
month you're fired
we're not offended the reason why we do
this is because we are very committed to
improving if you're not we're not the
company for you but in this company
you're going to improve with us and if
you don't believe in improving go work
for fortune 100 company that's done
improving and stay there quietly just
have a regular nine-to-five job that
they don't expect you to improve here
improvement is a priority at the highest
level what do you want to do if you
don't want to prove you can go home to
us we want everybody from the lowest $15
an hour job to the person making
$1,000,000 your income we want everybody
to be committed to improvement that is a
priority that we have at our company
number 24 perfect
let me explain to what I mean by perfect
people oh my gosh they're difficult okay
so what do I mean by perfect look you
will rarely hear me talk about my faith
matter of fact you won't get me talk
about my faith on a value team and you
know why let me explain to you why the
reason why is because I have a very hard
time with people who talk about their
faith so much to the point where it's it
becomes almost like they're more
righteous than you and they're more a
believer than you're under more of this
than you and all this other stuff that's
okay there's nothing wrong with that
and to the point where everybody is
below them
everybody is beneath them because
they're so perfect because they
righteous and they are forgiven and all
this other stuff to me I don't go to
church because I want somebody to make
me feel like I'm not imperfect I'm not
perfect I know I'm not perfect I'm going
there for somebody to say that even
though you're not perfect there's a
place for you right this message what I
just gave you in a business environment
it doesn't work with perfect people
there because they walk around like they
have this perfect life oh my wife and I
we never argue my husband we never argue
we love each other everything's fine
because we believe in the Lord and ah I
can't I can't deal with that it's very
difficult next small thinking let me
tell you I mean by small thinking
somebody who you're doing business with
that doesn't really realize what's about
to happen five years from now I remember
when he first got started Mario and I
were talking about it there was a group
of people who didn't fully know what was
gonna happen with our business moving
forward fully didn't know like I don't
know about I think it's good bum they
disappeared we had certain people that
started with value tame and when we had
two hundred subs and they said I don't
really know if this thing's gonna do
anything they disappeared at 200 subs we
had people at 2,000 subs that didn't
believe ie10 was gonna be what it is
today
right but the true believers are here
the reason why many of your loved mario
aguilar and let me put his handle up
here let's send some love to him at
aguilar social he's on twitter and on
instagram go follow him and send some
love to him the reason why you love
mario is because mario is a true
believer and mario has been there from
day one because he knew exactly what the
vision of both our company and value
tama was both of them people like people
like that right so small thinkers
unfortunately 90% of the world or small
small thinkers all they can think about
is what we're gonna do in the next week
what's gonna happen in next day in the
next month maybe a month maybe a quarter
very few people are saying you know what
I believe we can be there five years
from now I believe we can be there
twenty years from now I believe we can
be there ten years from now and I want
to be a part of it by the way don't fire
small thinking people sometimes they're
good for $15 an hour jobs and they're
still gonna get the day-to-day stuff
fixed but as long as as far as you want
it to take the company to whole
different level you need some of the
people that are bought into the vision
next twenty six you can't please them
you're gonna have certain people do
business with no matter what you ever do
nothing makes them happy period
twenty-seven people who change often let
me explain to what it means one day you
talk to them I don't want to be your
number one guy
sit I've changed I can't believe I don't
take more advantage of this relationship
because you're so amazing and the value
you bring to me up up up up up up next
month I can do whatever I want to do
because I am an entrepreneur I can do
whatever I want you're right
you can't do anything you want to do but
what's up with this changing all the
time you know you're like the weather
one day your rainy one minute you're
snowing one minute is sunny one minute
is gloomy which one is shown up today
who are we gonna meet today tell me so I
know in advance can I take the manual
out give me page number 88
it's who we're dealing with today
perfect now I know how to deal with you
today cuz I know who's shown up today
right
people who change often they don't know
this they lose a lot of good people in
their lives a lot of good people in
their lives because eventually they
drain other people of their energy to
love them they're draining because they
always change and they think it's okay
to do that and they can be like that
their entire lives you lose the right
people in your life forget about all the
other people that stick around because
it's your fan base and your fan club you
will lose the right people in your life
you do not you never ever want to lose
true believers who are loyal to you and
who you are as a human you never want to
lose them but unfortunately some people
do it all the time not knowingly next
twenty eight crap magnet I've said this
before you probably heard me say before
these are people that can't see attract
crap to themselves number twenty nine
self-inflicted wounds you've heard me
talk about this as well
there's always something bad happening
to them thirty people who are too honest
let me tell you who I'm thinking about
with this my dad is so honest it's out
of control
let me tell what I mean by my dad so I
have a friend from many many years ago
he is frightened of my dad and you know
why he's frightened of my dad here's why
it's frightening my dad because my dad
if you are 20 pounds overweight and
you've gained weight since the last time
you see this is my dad hey what happened
Gordo
what happened Gordo that's his line if
you're Hispanic you look fat you gained
weight what happened here that's my dad
and let me tell you something he will do
this all the time
I'll seem sitting down with a husband
and wife and he's talking about their
sex life I'm not bad you can't be doing
that buddy woody 10 tells a story
I want to explain to you sex say this is
sex okay on top of this Cup is honey
down here is if you eat all the
honey very quickly and you have sex all
the time you're eventually gonna eat the
okay
so don't do this take a nibble of the
honey just a little lots of we're you
know like a sexual you know all this
philosophers out there but the guys
that's entertaining as it gets if you're
around like that everybody loves my dad
but he's too honest there is a good area
for that there's also a bad area the
sensitive people cannot like people who
are too honest which leads me to the
next one point number 31 is sensitive
people sensitive people cannot take any
criticism from anybody which means the
only time they improve its based on
their own personal experience let me say
one more time sensitive people hear me
out if you're all if you're still here
for 90% of viewers that are done after
the first eight ten minutes if you're
still here for a ten percent of and you
were sensitive you know what happens
with sensitive people they can't take
constructive criticism for other people
so you know what happens sensitive
people can never learn from other people
they have to only learn it from
themselves which means sensitive people
have to make mistakes which means that
six the speed of success is always
delayed for sensitive people always
delayed for sensitive people you say one
more time
always delay for sensitive people I
don't know what I would I don't want to
hear this kind of stuff you're right you
don't have to hear this kind of stuff go
ahead and make the mistakes for yourself
three years later you were right we
could have saved that three years by the
way but you have to go through that
three years can't help because you're
sensitive last but not least is excuse
makers they got an excuse for everything
and that part it is what it is you can't
do anything about it there's just people
that make constantly excuses I can't
lead somebody and help somebody that's
constant making excuses now for those
you that watch this and you said I'd
love to have this on a PDF Mario again
send them some love Aguilar social and
tell them thank you this PDF can be
found below click on it go download the
PDF and circle the ones that are you see
I don't deal with this this is not me
this is not me this is not me this is
not me but I definitely deal with these
five things and then write out what are
you gonna do to improve those five areas
maybe go sit down with somebody and say
let me ask you a question somebody who
knows you did somebody was asking me
question the other day
Yuda and i told this guy good guy i said
listen the best way to understand
yourself is go to the people that know
you very well that you don't mind if
they say something very honestly that's
gonna hurt like who are those like my
dad can tell me anything it's not going
to hurt me tell me what's on your mind
right there are certain people let them
give you honest feedback about who you
really are then make your own pivots and
adjustments based on that I'm not
talking about negative people to go talk
to somebody that's level-headed that can
give you direct feedback and say these
are the things that I deal with what do
you think about these which one is me
they'll typically be able to tell you
and help you address those areas if
you're not number 31 which is what
sensitive to all the sensitive people
skip this exercise because it's gonna
offence you go make the mistakes on your
own take your time if you have the
courage to do this more power to you but
most are not willing to do it any
questions thoughts comments comments
below and if you have anything you want
to tell me directly after this video
tweet me at Patrick bet David again at
Patrick bet David and if you're watching
this video we've already crossed 700,000
subscribers which means we are only
three hundred thousand subscribers away
from our first alive value taming
conference where we all come together
for two and a half days and all we talk
about is business what we can do to take
your business to the next level I cannot
wait to meet you yeah I'm talking to you
I want to meet you you I can't wait to
meet you take everybody bye-bye
[Music]